india they don't know what to do with
bitcoin india has banned it they've
thought about banning it they didn't ban
it then they banned it and they thought
about not banning it india is confused
but india has one of the largest
populations in the world i've been to
india i went with one of our other
brothers i love india india is amazing
because it has a bunch of different
subcultures within the country and they
understand technology they understand
that they have a large population they
understand that they have a fast-growing
population they understand that they can
now compete on a global stage the
internet is the ultimate even playing
field anyone with an internet connection
can now play you don't have to move the
united states you don't have to move
somewhere else you can do it right from
your hometown and that is why india is
so interesting but india can't figure
out what to do with bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies we've seen over and
over and over again they've put forward
proposals they've thought about banning
it they have in some cases actually been
abrasive to it and then they've backed
away from it well we now are seeing are
reports that india will not ban bitcoin
it will not ban the trading of
cryptocurrencies instead what they are
going to do is they are going to
regulate it as a commodity there are
multiple people in india who have been
working tirelessly as part of the
bitcoin and crypto community to say that
india wants bitcoin they use the hashtag
they put it all over the internet they
say india wants crypto they use that
hashtag and they put it all over the
internet and ultimately what i believe
will happen in countries like india and
elsewhere around the world is that the
will of the people will ultimately
prevail the governments may not be as
educated the governments may not be as
experienced they may not be as familiar
with the technology and the advantages
and in some cases the governments and
the politicians may actually be trying
to protect the incumbents but you cannot
deny the will of over a billion people
who are saying this is superior
technology and we want it then if you go
and you look at the 1.4 billion indians
who will soon have legal access to
bitcoin when the government releases its
regulatory framework
now of course bitcoin has been banned
recently in india in january they made
the decision to not only ban bitcoin but
to ban all private digital assets and
they had a very encompassing definition
of what that meant the government began
to backpedal a little bit a couple of
months ago and by february 2022 the
authorities say that they are going to
release a legal framework for bitcoin
this will be everything from defining
how taxation will work around
transactions and gains but also who will
be allowed to use it and what venues how
should companies be allowed to use it
etc many people may forget that in india
one of the big things that they did at
one point was they basically applied
pressure to the banks and they said that
banks will not be allowed to service the
bitcoin and cryptocurrency industry if
you are a bank you cannot bank those
companies you cannot support those users
and so they tried to essentially choke
off the flow of capital from the legacy
system into the new system but what they
saw was that indians found a way the
indian population would not be stopped
by words that were written on a piece of
paper instead what they did is they
continued to adopt the asset they
continued to realize how powerful a
global store of value that was a
decentralized computer network the
strongest computer network in the world
one that had no censorship to it and one
that no one controlled and no one could
debase
and so capital continued to flow
adoption continued to increase we saw
everything from mining to actual users
on peer-to-peer exchanges continue to
grow and so of course
just like in other countries that we've
seen like in pakistan etc
the indian government has had to rethink
their strategy
we've seen china do the same thing where
they banned the miners and now they're
thinking wait maybe we made a mistake
maybe we should bring those people back
maybe we should actually reverse our
prior decisions
ultimately people realize bitcoin is
good for business and bitcoin is
inevitable you have an asset that no one
can control no one can shut down and so
ultimately the game theory is simple
if you want to set it out
you will miss out if you want to
participate
the sooner that you start to plug into
the network
the more you will benefit
if you want to wait then you will pay an
ignorance tax whether you are building
infrastructure whether you are buying
the asset or whether you are allowing
your business or your citizens to
participate and use these assets and so
ultimately when the game theory starts
every country will understand that these
rails these payment systems these assets
are superior and that's what we're
watching india do right now so it's
pretty cool to see that the will of 1.4
billion people is making the country
rethink a policy that they were very
very adamant about for the last couple
of years and so that's a message to
everyone around the world
if you and your fellow citizens believe
in something you do have a voice
the internet gives you the ability to
voice that opinion to stand up and to
say we want this and ultimately
politicians they do listen may take them
a long time they may not make it obvious
but if the people want something they'll
get it how cool is it that india now is
saying all right we hear you guys we're
going to go ahead we're going to create
a framework which not only is a
framework to allow you to do it also a
framework around taxation so they can
make money on it right but they are
going to allow uh indians to do this in
a legal manner yeah so i don't want uh
to do much public math here but i was
just looking up they have 1.4 billion
people in india the the earth has eight
billion just under eight billion i think
population wise that's 15
or so of uh of the total population of
the world so it's obviously a massive uh
tailwind for bitcoin and digital assets
but it's cool to see like someone else
has
that has historically been against it uh
i don't know if that necessarily had a
huge impact right we saw adoption
actually increase after they banned it
and you could see other countries maybe
china ends up doing something like this
but ultimately uh it's obviously a
positive any time you can have more
demand in the market and give more
people access within a legal framework
so they don't have to go outside uh and
risk getting in trouble legally
one point what is it one point like six
1.4 it's the second most populous
country in the world right one thing i
want to point out is that they recently
in january i believe banned
cryptocurrency in the sense of like
transacting with it um i wasn't really
sure kind of what legal framework they
went around but then they went ahead and
they rebuked it right and now they're
what 10 months later they are thinking
about uh making it legal and trying to
provide a legal framework by i think
february of next year um that's an
insane turnaround and i think the more
and more people look into this asset the
more more people that want this asset
the governments are basically their hand
is forced to allow this uh when you live
in a country like india it's a big
population though a lot of people coming
into bitcoin should be good for the
price and adoption what do you what do
you think i saw you ask in the chat like
what are people in india thinking do you
think uh like how do you think it how do
you think they're feeling right now do
you think this is like very very big
news or do you think the people that
were interested in uh bitcoin
specifically before this is just kind of
like okay i owned a bitcoin uh the
government really couldn't do anything
about it previously or do you think they
just feel safer now so i saw a couple of
people talking about this there's three
takeaways that i have from this one is
that every government is eventually
going to have to create a framework to
allow people to do this right and how
they do it some will be better some will
be more onerous whatever but every
single one of them will end up uh
allowing this to happen the second thing
is that uh it's very obvious they're
confused by it right they thought that
it was something like oh it'll just go
away it didn't go away now they're
trying to figure out what do we do so
there's like a ultimately or the
inevitability is that they're going to
accept it the medium term or short term
is that they're confused and then
there's this overarching thing of if
you're a country like india where you
have a massive population you're
actually pretty technology sophisticated
you can actually use this to drastically
leap forward right this is not a country
that is necessarily
so developed and so sophisticated and so
far ahead that they're complacent this
is a country that is still hungry for
progress and innovation and economic
prosperity and so what you can do is you
can use technology and the best thing
that you can look at is rather than try
to be a top down centrally planned
economy where you say to uh your
citizens hey we as the government know
better than you instead what i think it
should happen and it looks like it is
happening in india is they're going to
turn around they're going to say all
right here's the frameworks we need to
protect people to some degree we're
going to create this framework whether
they're good or bad that's the framework
now take these tools and go win on a
global stage and i think that ultimately
uh politicians around the world but
specifically in countries like india if
you simply look at it as hey i got 1.4
billion people and we have stars here
right we have absolute stars that are
part of our population and what we need
to do is get the hell out of their way
we need to give them the tools and the
technology and the education in order to
be successful and then literally just
get out of the way and if you just look
at it right just look at it from a
probability standpoint the united states
is about 330 million people india has
1.4 billion people they have a higher
probability that the next elon musk or
bill gates or mark zuckerberg or whoever
is sitting in india rather than the
united states it's just it's just a math
equation right now do they have the same
resources do they have same education do
they have same access to capital all
this stuff that's all up for debate but
from a pure pool that you're pulling
from the indian population is so large
and what we've seen is a lot of these
large venture funds private equity firms
et cetera they're going and they're
investing heavily in india now there's
multiple billion dollar businesses that
have been built in that country and so i
think what you're gonna start to see is
that the government's gonna wake up and
say wait a second we saw what america
just did in the technology industry for
the last 30 years they simply allowed
people to use this technology to build
massive businesses and for the most part
the government stayed out of the way
right there's not a ton of regulation in
the technology industry and that's
actually been a a huge tailwind for the
us and in these other countries what i
think they're going to start saying is
like hey give them the tools literally
let's go find the smartest people the
most uh innovative people we have in our
population let's give them technology
let's allow them to use these digital
assets and then literally get the hell
out of their way because if you do it
the right way what's going to happen is
that your citizens are going to lead you
into the future your citizens are going
to build the economy and kind of the the
world that you want to live in it's not
going to be the government and i think
that the governments around the world
who think that they know better than the
citizens end up struggling and they end
up holding back the progress of their
citizens versus simply saying hey we are
here to basically serve as uh guide
rails right and we're going to create
these frameworks and then literally tell
us what you need we'll get it to you and
then like just do your magic right
literally go build and in a country like
india with 1.4 billion people now that
the internet's available and they can
compete on a global stage i'm not
betting against them